president biden is pushing for congress
to pass stricter gun laws
following the two recent mass shootings
in colorado and georgia
that left 18 people dead in a week
the senate should immediately pass let
me say it again
the united states senate i hope some are
listening should immediately pass
the two house pass bills that close
loopholes in the background check system
vice president kamala harris joins us
now for an exclusive interview from
washington d.c
madam vice president good morning to you
we're very glad to see you this morning
there's so much to discuss so we'll get
started
listen it's clear that the president's
intention and his frustration are very
clear
but the reality is you guys just don't
have the votes
so what's your move well
on the issue of gun violence let's just
be very clear
um we are seeing tragedy after tragedy
after tragedy
the the we we are now learning the names
of the ten people in colorado including
that that that police officer who was
who
ran into fire in terms of gunfire
a father of seven children we are
looking at
in atlanta um and and all of those
folks who are all of them at the grocery
store um
in these establishments going about
their lives i know that
the gun doors are heartbreaking the the
personal stories but gail
here's why i mention it here's how i
mention it yeah because i'm going to
tell you something i've been working on
this for a long time i actually thought
that
sandy hook would have been the thing
that moved
congress how you when 26 and
seven-year-old
babies were slaughtered and they did not
act
and they did not act it is time for
congress to act
and stop with the false choices this is
not about getting rid of the second
amendment
it's simply about saying we need
reasonable gun safety laws there's no
reason why we have assault weapons on
the streets of a civil society they are
weapons of war
they are designed to kill a lot of
people quickly yeah we all
let us all agree that we need background
checks but the point here is
congress needs to act and and on the
house side they did
there are two bills which the president
is prepared to sign
and so we need the senate to act and
this is going to be about
your viewers and all of us pleading
um to the reason pleading to the hearts
and minds
of the people in the united states
senate to say enough with the
partisanship enough with the
ideological perspective on this let's
just be practical and agree
people who have been found to be a
danger to themselves and others should
not be able to purchase
so what will the administration do we
keep hearing about executive action
what does that mean madam vice president
what it means is that we need to take
action but but gail
let's be clear about this there is the
piece about executive action
but if we pass legislation that's
permanent
if we if we if the congress acts then it
becomes law
and that is what we have lacked that is
what has been missing
we need universal background checks you
know various states have done it
but there's no universal approach to
this and so what ends up happening
people can move from one state to
another depending on what the law is
we need to have a federal standard and
that is going to be accomplished
by the way we have structured our
democracy when the united states
congress acts the house is acted
now it's in the hands of the senate but
president is prepared
to sign it but madam vice president as
it stands right now you do not have the
votes
failing that is the president prepared
to take executive action
we should first expect the united states
congress to act i'm not
willing to give up on what we must do to
appeal to the hearts and minds and the
reason
of the members of the united states
senate i served in that body
and i believe that it is possible it has
to be possible
that people agree that these slaughters
have to
stop and this is again reject the false
choice and stop pushing it for sure stop
pushing the fall's choice
that this means everybody's trying to
come after your guns that is not what
we're talking about
and most reasonable most reasonable
people get that ted cruz said something
interesting yesterday
he called this conversation ridiculous
theater
that the gun laws that are being
proposed the changes would have done
nothing to stop those shootings
does he have a point is this a uniquely
american failure does he have a point
well the this is what every time there
is a slaughter
a mass shooting someone who does not
want to
be accountable for what we need to do
says well that wouldn't have prevented
this thing you know arguably if you took
that approach to any law you would argue
that we shouldn't pass any laws that are
designed to protect the health and
well-being of the american people
so listen yet again we have
a situation where there are seven
children who have lost their father
where there are families in in in two
big states of our country who are
mourning the loss
forever will be without their family
members their friends who were innocent
who were going about their lives and
were gunned down
and you know but guys i i want to be
again i'm going to start with where
i edward where i started which is i
thought sandy hook would be
right but the thing that compelled
everyone and it didn't i agree with you
but it didn't and and my question is how
do you change minds in the senate you
were in the senate
elections matter elections matter and
you know there are
a bunch of folks moms demand action a
bunch of
folks from gabby giffords to to the
brady folks
who we heard somebody join them and
let's let's
let's say that we're going to hold our
elected people accountable
if they're not going to be um with us on
what we need in terms of
reasonable gun safety laws but madam
vice president we heard from the head of
mom's demand to action
earlier in the broadcast who said the
president has it in his power to do
something right now
and the president has said he is
prepared to sign legislation
but he can also take executive action i
don't think the president is excluding
that but
again i i want to be clear that if we
really want something that is going to
be lasting
we need to pass legislation all right
vice president harris stay with us
we want to ask you about your personal
reaction to the recent racial attacks
and also get your take on the situation
unfolding at the border but first
we're going to take a quick break sure